[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we're going to be filling each
other in on a few things catching each
other up and in the process filling you
in catching you up on a number of things
that we have experienced uh in life just
living life as people who live lives
I've recently experienced a life change
that I didn't anticipate oh
um life change yeah it's um you're
looking over my body are you over over
promising I'm over promising and under
delivering but I'm I need to talk about
it because I need some well this is a
safe space I just haven't wrapped my
mind around it and will only be slightly
ridiculed I've also discovered a
Contraption in my travels that
um I just I I want you to know about oh
what you got from me I'm intrigued um
I've got a Little Dream I would like to
share with you that just happened this
morning I've got um
you know an event a traumatic event that
I that I was uh you know I kind of Lent
a hand in in a way that uh is not really
caused is not really true to my
it's not doesn't play on my strength but
I I got some feedback and apparently I
did a great job so I'm gonna break
that's why you're talking about it okay
uh you know you didn't think you were
good at you got good feedback uh and if
we get to it I've got something to talk
about that we have talked about but we
haven't talked about it uh extensively
in the context that I think it might
apply to us and our work so who knows
what we'll get to but boom I'm over
promising so we can under deliver good
good good well let's start with a dream
you said you know that the dream was
this morning you like woke up from the
dream
alarm clock
it was yeah it was no it was a uh it was
an early morning dream woke up went back
to early I'm thinking like a 3 A.M this
was maybe like the okay the first dream
cycle or something
but yeah okay are you questioning
whether or not it's like sir how do you
know that it was last night like you
just said this morning it sounds like
yeah it literally happened yeah I'm not
making up that it was this morning
sometimes when you wake up out of a
dream that's very visceral yeah and when
I woke up I was like oh I I was trying
to remember the most recent dream and I
could only get a previous dream you know
how that happens sometimes so I don't
remember the most recent dream but the
previous dream
was
maybe you can help me understand the
significance of this
okay I was at a restaurant with my
family
uh but it was not the current year it
was like Shepard was probably five or
six oh flashback that's weird and I did
not question that at all no you don't
really question you're doing your dreams
that's interesting thing it's you kind
of go with it we can learn something
from that yeah and in our waking lives
it was you know
uh what you might call like a uh
O'Charley's kind of restaurant you know
that adds up when Shepherd was five you
were big on the kids eat free oh I
didn't even know that but that's
probably why I was there in my dream
there was one next to the hospital where
our babies were delivered back in
Western Wake
uh I think it was what they call it now
um
I don't know that it was an O'Charley's
I'm just saying it was O'Charley's like
and can I say that it's not if you don't
have kids and you show up at a kids eat
free night at a place like O'Charley's
you are not gonna be a happy camper I
don't know if they do that they don't
separate you like kids are no kids
that's what they should have done with
smoking and non-smoking yeah when that
when that changed
because we remember but when that was a
thing I do think you can still smoke
okay Charlie's though yeah if you're
under it so if you're under if you're a
kid yeah kids get free cigarettes right
all the cigarettes they should separate
you know like that hot tub place we went
to in Durango they separated the
families from yeah kids ruin quite a bit
of things especially other people's kids
exactly and a lot of times your own kids
oh yeah yeah
but you know there are many Sweet
Moments I don't regret a moment I don't
well I don't really you don't regret any
of it before a moment I don't regret
being a dad you don't regret the Sweet
Moments um and I was having a sweet
moment with my you know like Shepard was
still in the like as a five six year old
whatever still in the very like uh you
know they're just so cute you know
they're just you kids are cute at some
point your kids are no longer cute my
kids are not cute anymore
um you said it so
I mean well you said it you said it
that's it I emphasize that in an
insulting way I'm sorry in the tape on
there good looking guys at the table
next to us like very close by the way it
was almost like we were in a booth
and we're kind of back to back okay was
Matt Damon hey
um he's been in a lot of movies and I I
think the reason that Matt Damon was in
my dream just just to kind of give you
the Practical reason is that
I was stumbled upon a tick tock of him
being interviewed talking about Tom
Cruise telling a story about the stunts
that he does in Mission Impossible
it's not even a recent clip it's
something you've probably seen where
like Matt Damon is essentially doing an
impersonation of how intense Tom Cruise
is when he tells you about the stunts
that he does okay
and it kind of stuck with me apparently
I saw the beginning of that and I I
scrolled but the interesting I didn't
finish it just to be clear when I kind
of knew where it was going I was like I
got it Matt Damon
but one of the things that happened in
my mind apparently then manifested
itself in my dream is that the Tom
Cruise Matt Damon sort of connection
ended up being
Matt Damon with the haircut that Tom
Cruise had in The Last Samurai so like
the culturally appropriated like Samurai
haircut
that he had in that movie was the one
that Matt Damon had
um in this and I'm actually confused
because Matt Damon also also in uh he
also did a similar thing
Samurai movie and was and got the same
criticism right so maybe that was also
happening okay but it was like a Super
Cuts version of The Last Samurai haircut
describe it I can't picture it a bowl
cut uh well I mean essentially and I'm
not saying that I'm I'm not saying I'm
guilty of this but if you have long hair
and you put your hair up in a bun and
you leave some of it down but there's
other things that and then if you dress
like a samurai then you oh okay you've
completed the package I do that
sometimes and I say it's a viking thing
so that it's not appropriation because
you know yeah that's my Heritage so
anyway it's a viking thing he says but
he had the Supercuts version of that and
what I mean by that is he essentially
had the haircut that many of our friends
including you had in high school where
it was completely shaved the undercut
then he had taken the top part and put
it in a uh not a bun but like a pony
yeah it was very like Supercuts Last
Samurai that's what I was thinking at
the time I was like oh he must be he
must be making a film and he's just got
it's a break and he must be making that
mistake again he's a O'Charley's to
smoke cigarettes with children
uh in between you know scenes but
I got this idea that I was gonna kind of
unleash on my family in the dream and
that was
um I was going to and it's ironic that
we're coming out of our company-wide
meeting which often starts with people
talking about celebrity sightings
but
what I was telling my kids was
guys guess what celebrity I saw today
and it was kind of like I was playing I
spy and it was going to be the surprise
was that it's Matt Damon and he's right
behind you
and I did that and I don't remember many
details but I woke up because I was so
anticipating the surprise of saying it's
Matt Damon but then Matt Damon would
have heard you say that oh yeah and that
was the plan oh it was for my for me to
say it's Matt Damon and then him to turn
around and my whole family's looking at
him
that was the plan he would have loved it
it didn't come to fruition because he
would have whipped that ponytail around
might would have taken off
one of your boys it was only a couple
inches short I do want to clarify that I
had the soccer undercut as a senior in
high school but it was never long enough
to put in a in a thing and I never
attempted that
I question have you seen the our prom
picture
you think it was long enough yeah it was
you I never put it in there and I think
it was like I think you could have done
it on top and maybe not all the way back
yeah I think you had enough but I didn't
which you that's the point I'm making
you didn't do it I didn't cross that
line yeah I think you missed an
opportunity it's you know I'm
self-conscious about it but and I do it
out of practicality but I just think
that
I don't know it's a weird thing to judge
you know what I'm saying because it's
like if you've got long hair as a man
and you don't want it to be in your face
what are your options
ponytail
I I you think I should have a ponytail
you want me to have a pony
I don't want to talk about it I don't
want to give input oh well you sound
like you were
I was talking about me yeah I know but
and you're making it about the implied
judgment was that you were too good for
Ed to ever have a top knot
and so I'm like here I am sometimes I
have one
I I'm just I'm just making it about me
okay well all right okay so you love
mine that's what you're saying you love
it when I do it I just you know I just I
don't have to have an opinion on it and
I don't I officially
it's good to know that's good to know
don't I had a dream honestly I was
starting to think about the dream I had
because I remembered it oh and then
that's why I wasn't thinking of I wasn't
listening to you oh great so I didn't
hear you talking it was good enough and
then I like you brought me back and here
we were talking about you now yep and I
was thinking about me it was my dream
okay so what happened what's your dream
my dream's over I woke up
I really don't want to talk about it
wow I was at a camp okay and
um I didn't want to and I and I think I
was my age but that wasn't a problem
um that wasn't a weirdo over the campers
uh they were they were like high school
college age it was kind of weird okay
and of course
you weren't a counselor you were a
camper yeah I was
hello fellow campers kind of a thing
and um I didn't want to go to any of the
programming so I didn't and then I was
just kind of moping around
and uh people started coming up to me
and saying like
what are you doing you're not
and I didn't have a good reason I was
just I was just like the biggest Downer
at this Camp just moping around not
doing any of the activities that was my
dream
and I woke up sounds thanks for sharing
I did I know so I'm like sounds fun you
reminded me of it I'm like and I don't I
don't I didn't it wasn't a good showing
and I and now I woke up not feeling
I can't shake the feeling of it
of Camp of being disappointed in myself
oh
I think that's what I'm experiencing
right now this is actually kind of funny
because uh as you know Shepard uh return
from two weeks at um kind of like a
scuba slash
sailing camp water camp and uh add the
recommendation of a mythical Beast yeah
I don't often check my Instagram DMS but
uh because it's rarely of any benefit to
me
um okay but we're gonna talk we uh
we talked about
how much Shepard was enjoying scuba
diving right here on this podcast and a
mythical Beast who would listen to that
episode sent a message and said might I
highly recommend this camp where he can
go and scuba dive
and I was like this is great we've been
trying to figure out where we're going
to get Shepard to do for the summer I
kind of want to occupy him uh he
occupies himself but you know like I
just I've always handled that passion
man I've always wanted him and it wasn't
just about the passion of scuba diving
it was that but it was
the camp experience right me and you
grew up in church and so we had all
these like
so many groups now a lot of them were
very emotionally manipulative but
setting that aside for a second
there was these very pivotal experiences
like going on a mission trip or going to
Camp where you just had these things
where the way I've described it is so
much life stuffed into this one week or
this two weeks that then has this really
outsized impression in your memory as
you end up growing up yeah
community-based experiences and you know
we just don't have that because we're
not a part of that kind of community
anymore and I miss that aspect of of
church right
in in the youth group things that kids
can experience now there's like team
sports and that kind of thing but he
doesn't really do team sports Rick he's
he's in a music and individual things
he's on his one-wheel outside so the
water Camp could be well it could be it
and uh as you know when he got down
there and he and there was you know
kudos to Shepard for going down there by
himself
um
not knowing anyone not taking a friend
and also like you know it's across the
country I mean Jesse did go out there
with him initially he flew back by
himself but
but I was like Shepard could handle this
because he gets in and where he fits in
and he's kind of good at that
but a number of circumstances made the
adjustment over the first few days very
difficult because not he was miserable
he was having a hard time and I was like
Kenny had a cell phone yes exactly he
had a he had a Lifeline to his parents
which is something that we never had
when we got dropped off at camp long
story short was he eventually adjusted
and ended up having the best time of his
life he wants to go back next year he
was super enthusiastic not just about
the activities but about the people and
just the place and he's telling us about
the specific experiences of when they
did this around the campfire or whatever
yeah and and I'm like as he's saying
this stuff I'm like yes yes yes like I'm
that of the year because it was mine it
was actually it was a Fan's idea but
then I took it and made it Mighty and
gave it to my son yeah he's experiencing
these things and having you know the
kinds of things that are meaningful and
thankful uh and thanks to you for
getting us into scuba diving and to
begin with okay you're dulling out I
love it
um but well I'm about to throw you under
the bus a little bit
because when I when he started telling
me about all that and I was like yeah
you know
I love that you got to experience that
like it's like it's so like I feel I I
know the me as a kid that got those
kinds of experiences and just loved
every second of it and I was like my
only Camp experience was one week at
Camp Carraway and of course I wasn't
gonna go by myself because that just
wasn't something that any of us did back
then I went with Link and Link
hated it and did not take a the
whole week nope and we never went back
because he hated it and I'm I've always
held it against you a little bit that
you kind of ruined camp for me because
it was like I had such a good time like
you've ever protected you do you
remember those Camp counselors like they
like that first night there was that big
bonfire and then like came out of the
woods and stuff like I just love that
kind of stuff and then there's like
they're singing yeah we're all singing
about Jesus but we're singing together
and like you just didn't like it you
hated the whole thing every bit of it I
was constipated oh it was okay so it was
affecting your brain I didn't like I
didn't like swimming
you didn't like I was I was the bunks
you didn't like the fast showers but
like the way I thought about shower and
other people could see you and it was it
was called the 60-second shower and you
could poop and other people could see
you I think
yeah but it's all part of it and then
there was the memory and the flashlight
Wars it was just like yes it was at
night and it was oh yeah dark and scary
and people are shining flashlights in my
face and pursuing me it was basically
like
I don't know I I needed a backup friend
for these things you know I'm sorry man
I needed somebody who was willing to go
wishing those things I wish I would have
been more open to it but anyway
Shepherd didn't even need a friend
and I actually think the fact that he
went uh without having a friend and he
said this it's funny like the wise
things that he was saying on the trip
back
uh as we were driving him home from the
airport he was like I'm actually glad I
didn't go with a friend because if I had
gone with a friend I would not have
connected with the other campers as much
and I'm like wow this is awesome it was
Lincoln was about his eight actually he
was a little bit older because it was
late when we finally talked him into
going to Camp he did go with a friend
they had an awesome time and then
it was uh
the time he didn't work out for him to
go back the next year I can't remember
exactly why I think it's because
the next year we went on tour and he
came with us which was a great
experience and but he really wanted to
go back in any aged out of it and I was
like oh he started too late and now
Lando at 13
he's more like me you know it's like
he's got a lot of anxieties associated
with that type of thing we put him in a
tennis camp that's just a day camp
and he was like he made the decisions
like I think I like tennis I want to I
want to get into that and he and it was
a great experience so much so that he
signed up for a second week oh that's uh
that he did Big Win but it was just a
day camp so you don't really have the
best parts what if you turn it into a
Sleepaway Camp what if you set up a
little tent for him yeah buddy nobody
else is doing this a solo camping
sleeper will give you water and some of
those meals you could warm up in yeah
I'd love to get him maybe next year he'd
be able to do that well I mean the thing
I love about this is that this Camp you
can go up until your senior year like so
he can go he can go all through high
school yeah and then there's people that
come back and be in our counselors who
knows maybe you know maybe he'll such a
big turn from like you were telling
about those first two days and how
bad of a time he was having and then
he's like and I was trying to go back
forever and I was telling him it's
classic it was funny because I was like
Shepherd and the kids don't listen but I
was like this is a story as old as time
showing up at summer camp and being
miserable the first couple of days
you're adjusting to so many things not
to mention the fact that it was the the
the low the minimum temperature was 83
degrees at night and they didn't have AC
so just you know this is hot this is on
the East Coast yeah
um and
but yeah it but then you when you get
through it and this is the thing I
really loved for it for him was this
like getting that life experience that
is like things that are worth it
almost always are kind of difficult at
the beginning
and if you just like yeah hey come get
me and you go you gotta poop early
I don't think he didn't talk about not
pooping so I think he
think he pooped fine
yeah yeah yeah yeah we would you know if
I could go back in time if I had the
ability to go back in time people say
this a lot of times
um if you could go back in time and
influence any one thing at least right
now it would be going back and just
handing like not going camping 12 year
old Lincoln enema
like it all oh so I was still invited
like a weird grisly man comes comes out
of the woods at campus like here kid put
this in your ass bend over
I'm a time traveler
trust me and it's you and it's me but
you don't know in a bear costume no I'm
not interested I'm in futuristic clothes
I don't give it hell no I don't give it
I give
oh I don't administer it future you I am
finished no no no squeezing I know no no
no no no I hate don't put my music
I'm just an adult man who is handing an
enema to a kid who will then do what he
will with it I'll give him instructions
as well
I probably gotta meet me it's me as well
and be like make sure he does this you
know because if I gave it to you be like
I'm gonna throw this in the trash but if
I'm like hey tall skinny guy come over
here I'm you from the future make your
friend do this
don't do it to him just make sure he
does it sounds like you're trying to get
your your past self to get no I'm not
I'm not into I'm the only my only
interest is you enjoying Camp if you
took a in the first day or two at
camp we all lies would be different who
knows where we'd be I'm still that way
I'm still that way if I go on a trip I I
now I gotta make it happen
that first day and then after that it's
okay if you I take it's like I've told
my body you don't have to conserve
anything here
you don't have to you don't have to you
don't have to hold it all back right
we're fine I think this is common but
this is why I take preemptive fiber like
48 hours before travel
hit the psyllium husk
get it hard
hit it yeah and I I travel with the
Animus I'm saying as a back if you do
preemptive fiber you may not need it I
know I know
it always comes to this I don't know how
we get there every time
it's part of life I do believe in camps
um I want to give a quick promotion go
over to the mythical kitchen Channel
post Malone had a last meal with Josh he
didn't die but if he were to be
dying and this is what he wanted to eat
Josh made him his like favorite stuff
yeah also um Gabriel fluffy Iglesias if
you're a fan did a last meal hey it was
awesome check out all of us best food
show on the internet listen I mean very
proud we're obviously we're obviously
big fans of hot ones and big fans of
Sean over hot ones and Friends uh and
been on the show uh and well unabashedly
say that we would love to have a food
interview show that was as successful as
hot ones but I just absolutely love the
fact that fluffy Gabriel literally said
while he was filming he was like this is
like hot ones but fun because he wasn't
being tortured he was being given
exactly what he wanted to eat
um I just love that show man Tom Hanks
check it out
earbiscus is supported by chime it's
summertime people are going on vacation
splurging a little so it's the perfect
time to start building your credit with
a secured chime credit Builder Visa
credit card a better way to build your
credit you can build your credit score
safely with everyday purchases and
on-time payments plus there's no annual
fee interest or credit check to get
started and you can build credit using
your own money the perks don't end with
a credit Builder either if you have a
chime checking account you can get your
direct deposit up to two days early and
with that qualified direct deposit you
can overdraft up to 200 without fees by
signing up for spot me and chime will
spot you up to your limit when you make
a purchase that exceeds your balance
plus you have access to over sixty
thousand fee-free ATMs that can be found
using the chime app that's more than the
top three leading Banks combined and you
can pay friends through chime no matter
what bank account they use and cash out
your money fee free start building your
credit up open a chime checking account
with at least a 200 qualifying direct
deposit get started get started at
chime.com ear that's chime.com ear the
chime credit Builder Visa credit card is
issued by stride Bank NA member FDIC
chime checking account and 200
qualifying direct deposit required to
apply out of network ATM withdrawal fees
May apply on-time payment history may
have a positive impact on your credit
score late payment May negatively impact
your credit score results May Vary ear
biscuits are supported by Rosetta Stone
now you know I learned French in high
school I took a handful of years
didn't use Rosetta Stone I kind of wish
I would have I didn't no offense to uh
Miss Slaughter Sewells I took three
years and learned less than you did I
think I slept more in class but if
you're looking to learn a new language
now Rosetta Stone is the most trusted
language learning program available on
desktop or as an app and it truly
immerses you in the language you want to
learn I would love to brush up on my
French from high school so when I do go
to frost which I would like to go back
to France I can connect I can speak the
language or at least raise some eyebrows
when I I try to put my best foot forward
you know yeah order a croissant
Rosetta Stone has used trusted experts
for 30 years with millions of users and
offers over 25 languages like French
Spanish Dutch Arabic Korean just to name
a few and it works for fast language
acquisition as it has no English
translation so you really learn to speak
listen and think in that language
Rosetta Stone even has built-in true
accent features that give you feedback
on your pronunciation like a personal
trainer for your voice it's really an
amazing value lifetime membership has
all 25 languages for any and all trips
and language needs in life a 299 dollar
program but with our code you can get it
for just a hundred and forty nine
dollars don't put off learning that
language there's no better time than
right now to get started for a limited
time you can get Rosetta Stone's
lifetime membership for 50 off that's
149 dollars for unlimited access to 25
language courses for the rest of your
life redeem your 50 off at
rosettastone.com ear today
[Music]
um we visited Lily Lily moved into a new
uh house
and so she wanted us to come up there
and and see your living situation we all
went both boys to visit her and um it's
just cool like
Farmhouse would like I don't know five
of her friends
kind of out in the middle of nowhere was
kind of wild that's cool
um
but it was pretty cool there were horses
around there
wild there was a dog outside oh that's
an outside dog whose dog is well
sometimes he walks into my bedroom
Lily said I open my sliding glass door
who's talking here comes a dog like a
neighbor's dog
but the horses are somebody's oh yeah
they're in they're fenced okay so Amy
was
it was nice to see firsthand you know
your daughter's living situation and
just kind of and to meet the friends and
kind of get a Vibe for it so then
whenever you're talking to her you can't
bless you you can uh bless her
with a little bit more inside
information inside you bring some stuff
I I just my heart was warm because she
said I was like what do you need us to
bring and she was like I need you to
bring my speakers and my record player
and my records and I was like that I can
do because that was the thing that when
she went off to college that's the thing
that I bought I was like I got to make
sure you set up with some speakers
and your your records and stuff and then
when she went off to college she didn't
end up taking it and I was a little bit
hurt so I was nice that like it was nice
that she that she wanted that because
that was like that's the thing that I
felt like that I was contributing to her
living situation right and she may have
been just just doing it to make you feel
good she if you may give it to the
horses we don't know no I could tell she
said we set it up no in the in like the
communal area where everybody's like
hanging out like oh now we can have
dance parties
like yeah that's right yeah we stayed in
an Airbnb nearby and
this place had something that I just
haven't seen in a while at first glance
I was like okay yeah they have it but
then I got closer and I realized this is
a newfangled version of this thing and I
gotta give it a shot air hockey nope any
other guesses
foosball
it is recreational
um okay Airbnb
pool table
what will be a newfangled pool table air
hockey
uh
they had a trampoline oh um full size
full size
and no net
it had a net but the net was different
and there was something else that was
fundamentally different there was a sign
on it that says guests please do not use
the trampoline because it was an Airbnb
it did have a sign and I think it's like
the boilerplate thing that they make the
the renters the uh the rental agreement
they like it's part of it for insurance
purposes they're like only jump for five
minutes at a time yeah only jump one
person at a time that's no fun
and of course take your shoes off and
you're still liable for anything that
goes wrong but don't jump more than five
minutes at a time really yeah why don't
jump on it don't jump with a friend
really the only way to get high is to
jump with a friend that's right you get
that popcorn thing
I look down under this thing have you
ever seen a spring free
trampoline no this thing was wild it's
like I mean it did have here's a picture
of one right here it it it does have a
um
a net around it but then you see how
this there's no springs so the whole
material is
the thing that you jump on is it goes
all the way to the edge and it's the
normal jumping material and instead of
having Springs around the edge that you
don't want to like drop a foot through
and they're like putting the whole thing
pancakes the whole thing is vertical and
underneath and it so it kind of looks
like it's a Max spring it's a big the
whole thing is one spring these things
that are like they're at a 45 degree
angle from the top down to like an
another layer and then they so it
smushes yeah as much as kind of like a
mattress and so each of these things is
like a
um just like a plastic shaft like a
plastic tube at a 45 degree angle
attached to the top and bottom rims and
it doesn't the bounce on this thing was
was very satisfying so it was even more
than normal it was it was not if you get
a super high-end trampoline with springs
you can I mean like an Olympic
trampoline you're going to bounce a lot
higher than you can on this thing but
for like a normal run-of-the-mill
trampoline that you would get for your
you know your pre-teens or whatever
obviously you see all the advantages of
this design it's so much safer but it's
um you don't get the flying spring
effect
yeah which we used to have to deal with
did that ever happen like I know Ben was
the one with the trampoline oh yeah and
he was on that thing all the time
uh yeah we had flying Springs and
sometimes Rusty flying Springs it would
break and it flies across so most of the
time it flies and gets caught but
sometimes it flies and we go into the
woods
um
and even if there's that blue padding
over the Springs you're still going to
hit that stuff you end up hitting if you
get to it but his didn't have any of the
padding he just had the holes and there
was no netting around it
no one had netting in 92 on there no on
their thing because we would run and the
whole point was to be able to run from
the ground and jump on it or didn't jump
off of it onto the ground this is
actually better on the body like I could
feel it when I got into this thing it
actually felt good it was inviting well
it's because I mean the whole thing is
like giving it's not a sponsor
but turns out as far as I can tell
there's only one company that makes
these spring free trampolines that's
what they're called yeah maybe it's a
pattern did you uh did you get video
footage of this
uh uh I mean a man gets on a middle-aged
man gets on a trip I'm sorry to say that
I did not get footage of me because I
didn't dawn on me
until here's footage of land though I
mean
doing a little popcorn
so it's I mean from this vantage point
you really can't tell that
it's they're pretty different than a
normal trampoline
but I'm just glad to know that advances
in technology are not leaving
trampolines behind yeah because
trampolines uh they were kind of on the
fence for a while then I know they could
have gone the way of the dodo because
kids get hurt on them but thanks to
springless
not a sponsor well that actually is a
great segue into the the update I wanted
a little story I wanted to tell you and
speaking of kids getting hurt
okay
um
as you know
Shepherd is a big fan of the one wheel
um and that I felt like a good and bad
dad
in getting it and again this was
something that you got for your kids
first yeah and I was and now the only
person who Rises is Shepherd well I I me
and Shepard and and lock also now he's
home for the summer we'll we'll look
we'll go out in fact this weekend we've
got a whole like multi-day
one will we're staying on the west side
because Jesse's got all this stuff
happening at the house and uh it's just
a one-wheel Extravaganza we're gonna get
lost if you don't know what a one wheel
is this is an electric powered
wheel
in the middle of a skateboard
so you put your you put your feet on
either side of the wheel and then this
thing goes and it's kind of like uh
uh Segway kinda it's that like a Segway
meets the skateboard yeah Segway meets
the skateboard they will go fast and uh
uh Lando broke his his wrist falling off
of his and uh he's not really been
wanting to get on it again yeah they're
dangerous I mean let's just be straight
up they're dangerous and it's we met a
guy on a on a plane well we met uh uh
broken collarbone well we should shout
him out because he's like he's a
YouTuber he works with Corridor Digital
but he's also a person named like Rin
sounds right professional one-wheeler we
will uh if I can I will say his name um
right now I'm saying Ren but I think
that's not quite right so we're going to
overdub what his name actually is in
those places
unless it is that
um great guy
who yeah we talked to as far as we
continue and uh yeah he had broken his
collarbone and he has broken several
other bones
it's of course he's going like 30 on the
thing but Shepard is a demon on this
thing he is just Relentless and you know
he wears a helmet most of the time
sometimes I catch him without it but I
gotta wear that helmet but I was it's
funny because what he does is he uh
you know we've got three of them
and so me and lock and Shepard could all
do it at the same time yeah and us too
we what this means is that Shepard is
he's on it every single day every single
day if I get home he's not home and I'm
like where sometimes he's like dead my
battery died and he's like literally
like seven miles from home
uh in fact is he using it as a form of
transportation or just to he goes
Joyrides well yeah I mean A and B it's
the kind of one of the same like once
you find yourself next to like the
Starbucks you know five miles from your
house you're like it makes you feel
independent as a 14 year old you can
just that's good yeah and it's something
that bike experience that we had it's
what we had as kids and that I was
always like I felt bad that we raised
our kids in a city essentially like
we're not really in a city but you know
we're in the suburbs but
we were gone all the time we talk about
it all the time about that independent
spirit that you gain if you were a child
of the 80s does he make friends with
like the tire repair man I like to think
that he does and like the the cobbler
time travelers from the future that are
trying to hand him enemas yeah the taco
tent people
um
but I I'm a little there's a you know I
have this like a little a little bit I'm
not very much of a worried dad like
you know I don't really have that Gene
I'm mostly like I just love the fact
that he's out there somewhere I don't
know where he's at of course I do I
could look on my phone and track him
it is 2023 but I just love the fact that
he has these experiences but the thing
is is that he's got friends that come
over and of course oh he wants to put he
wants to put them on these things and of
course they want to get on him too and
we do have like pads and stuff that we
have available to them and we make sure
that all the friends that wear a helmet
and I try to say give all your friends
full pads wrist guards knee pads elbow
pads because we live in a hilly
environment and they're getting on a one
wheel for the first time I bet you this
story ends with nobody receiving any
injuries and I think I told you that
we've had a couple of incidents where
you know one of his friends will just
completely bust his ass and then have to
seek first aid at our home
uh and then well you know one time one
of his friends busted his ass real hard
and they didn't tell anybody
and then like his mom like days later it
wasn't his ass it was his arm right well
when I say bust ass I mean it's a
general term for falling down
um but yes it was his arm and his hip
and his knee it was all skin up
again things that happened to us all the
time growing up like in a friend group
yeah in 1987. the curriculum methylate
on that there was always one friend who
just was skin up real bad like everybody
had one who's skinned up this week
but uh and we didn't wear helmets either
which was stupid we got away with a lot
so
we've had a couple of incidents where
the mom will find out later and then be
like we had one mom like text us
pictures of the the the the swords
she wasn't mad it was just more like do
you like did you guys know about this
more like it was a kind of informative
and like you know kids still friends
with Shepherd it wasn't a problem
but I was literally on the phone with
our friend Mike not science Mike but our
friend Mike from North Carolina
uh
two nights ago and we haven't talked in
a while so we're catching up he's like
how are the kids and I'm
saying well you know
Shepherd you had a great time at camp
and he loves one wheeling in fact he's
one-wheeling right now and you know I
never know where he's at he's just
one-wheeling all over the place
uh I told you he put He had put 600
miles on that one on one of the one
wheels that he doesn't even ride that
much just to give you a perspective here
the kid is basically crossed the country
on this thing so
which you know the longer you go the
more you increase the chances that
you're going to bust your asses oh yeah
but he hasn't had too bad of a fall yet
but I was like I don't know where he's
at in every couple of weeks you know one
of his friends falls on this thing and
then we have to like I'm like telling
Mike and I'm kind of like you know I
mean he's like yeah man it's like with
us from skateboarding we were kids you
know and you know reminiscing
and
then I go
into the house and I have my therapy
which I do online and I'm in the middle
of my therapy session
and Shepard just runs upstairs opens the
door and he's like Dad
I'm not going to say his name but he's
like my friend
my friend took a real bad fall on the on
the one wheel
you got to help us
Jessie's out of town okay so the person
who should be there that could actually
do something like informed and and do a
good job with this is not present so
it's just me yeah and I'm in therapy man
this is this is literally this is me too
currently
and so and my therapist was like I get
it man dad you know Dad duty calls or
whatever and I was like yep I gotta go
I mean the way that he was delivering
the news you did you definitely felt
like you had to get up and run down well
you know I didn't think I was going to
come in and see like a jaw hanging off
by one side or anything like that I
didn't think it was going to be that bad
I I just figured this was in skins up
territory and when I got to the kitchen
skint up territory was where we were at
okay you know and it was you know it it
shakes you up but he was able to it
happened like
half a mile from home and instead of
calling me
they walked back like Shepard like
picked up his one wheel and one wheeled
and he walked
and like he's sitting there and he's
pale as a sheet and he's pretty badly
scant up but like it's not like dirty it
doesn't have it's just like Road Rash
basically on his knee his elbow and his
shoulder okay
again he had his helmet on but he didn't
have any pads on
and so you could kind of tell he's a
little bit in shock right and I'm you
didn't know I'm not the most comforting
presence right that's not uh that's not
it's just not my thing you know I got a
lot of other gifts that is one that the
whoever makes these decisions decided to
leave out of the program okay yes right
you have other gifts and uh and so
um
the uh my first thought was okay don't
laugh I mean like like I just can't be
honest with you like that's don't laugh
that's the first thing that comes to my
mind don't laugh at this kid
you know I don't know why I'm sadistic
so I was like he was panicking a little
bit and he was beginning to breathe kind
of like labored but you knew it when you
saw him it wasn't as big of a deal as he
was no he was shaking up he was shaking
yeah yeah and uh
and I didn't think he like broken his
arm or anything oh you never know I'm
not I'm not a
I don't I'm not an x-ray technician but
he seemed like it was just be skinned up
and so you didn't ask him to move you
got to move your fingers if you can move
your fingers nothing above the fingers
is broken well is is the I'm sure that's
not correct but that's that's what I
always thought hey you can move your
fingers it's not broken that's the first
thing I would have said well he no he
was he was able to go like this
okay move your elbow and it was more
like it ain't broken he had like hit it
hard skint it right and so I was like
okay I'm gonna get you cleaned up and
bandaged up if I can find the things you
know this is the McLaughlin house
this is like it's almost like a Walmart
like 18 months after the apocalypse you
know what I'm saying like stuff has been
kind of run through we don't know we're
not well organized and we may not have
what you need just to be honest with you
so I was like call your mom first of all
so she can be on her way
um but I'm gonna get you cleaned up
there was a moment where he before I was
able to clean him up where he started
breathing pretty hard and then he was
like I can't see I can't hear
I can't breathe oh no and uh panicking
and Shepard was he's about to think was
was feeding into this he's like damn
something's wrong I was like he's just
he's just shaking up I took uh a uh a
washcloth okay see I can't I can't hear
I took a washcloth I wet it I'm in a
tongue and I just went up and I put it
on I gently put it on his forehead
without laughing and
and five seconds later he's like I'm
coming back
so yeah he was about to faint
and then you didn't tell him put his
head between his knees uh
I didn't think of that because you got
it washcloth you should tell him that
washcloth didn't put that every time I
got him back yeah he came back yeah
critique me because I'm the hero of this
story by the way I'm just saying it next
time the head needs to go down because
he's gonna if he was sitting down if he
did faint the head is still gonna hit
something well I mean Shepard was
holding him
he was spotting him he's okay buddy what
do you want me to tell you he was
panicking so uh he came back and then uh
he can't you know he came fully too I'm
sorry we tried to get some peanut butter
in him
but he didn't want that uh because
Shepherd was like you've only eaten a
bowl of cereal to hold the whole day it
was like 7 P.M so peanut peanut butter
has sugar in it but I mean maybe a juice
yeah well next time I was just thinking
about I'm gonna get this kid bandaged up
and get his mom here I mean I'll be
honest with you like I I was like I kind
of want to offload pass this guy off
before I burst out into loud I want to
offload this kid on the responsible part
uh but I felt bad because again the one
wheels are our house don't get me wrong
I'm giving you this advice but I would
have been the one fainting but so far I
haven't done anything wrong though the
washcloth saved the day okay
and uh then I clean them up you know and
I didn't you know they were like where's
the hydrogen peroxide and I was like
guys I didn't you're not supposed to put
hydrogen peroxide on wounds that's a
myth it's actually it can it causes them
to not heal as quickly because just look
it up look up look it up on the internet
it's not good to put on wounds and you
don't want to put alcohol
what you want to do is you want to just
clean it with soap and water you want to
clean if you know you you know if
they're like open wounds or whatever you
want to go to the hospital or the
emergency room but if it's just yours I
heard some ticket Tiki tacky over there
yeah you just clean it with soap and
water no what does peroxide do it just
makes it it damages the tissue
it harms the tissue and delays the
healing yeah there are things you can
put on there like now you can click away
or whatever but like I was like I'm
gonna let the mom deal with like
dressing these with like the proper like
antibiotic or whatever choice that she
wants to make I'm a soap and water guy
gently clean and then I we I found the
the like the big pads and I taped them
on and then I gauzed over that like I
you know so they'll stay in place I like
I mean I was like and the whole time I
was like you're doing a great job right
you know I was like because I just don't
this is not my thing I don't I haven't I
haven't come to the rescue of many
people you know okay and so but then I
was like when's your mom gonna get here
you didn't lose him you didn't lose him
Victory he sits down uh and they're he's
like he seems to be fine and he's also
saying like thank you
he was very he was very grateful this
kid very nice manners great well man a
nurse
and um
so then I kind of forgot about it I
didn't talk to Jesse like Jesse's so
busy with where she was she was out of
town doing something and like I didn't
talk to her for like two days yep I did
call her but she never answered
okay
she finally texted me sorry I'm crazy
which meant I'm busy and
but then she calls me the next day when
I'm here at work
and she's like
did so and so
take a bad fall on the one wheel I was
like yeah I tried to call you last night
and tell you all about it and um she
said well his mom said
tell your husband
thank you for taking such good care what
of my son
what he was very very caring
you're surprised by this and I was like
well yeah I didn't laugh at him I didn't
I did not laugh at the kid and I
bandaged him up
and I and I believe that I was uh and I
kept telling him he's gonna be talking
about you for years I kept telling him I
was like you're going to be here today
you're gonna be okay you're fine here
cold claw I'm back all of it yeah you
know now if you if something had been
really messed up if he had broken
something I'm not saying I would I think
mostly this is just the fact that he
really wasn't that hurt I don't I don't
know he was really hurt
no but I I might have unraveled you know
if that yeah if there was skin hanging
off or something is showing
I would have taken him to the emergency
room don't get me wrong I wouldn't be
like hey your mom's gonna have to take
you to the emergency room in a little
bit when she gets here I've been having
this like catastrophic fantasy when I've
been walking the dogs in it fantasy
um well it's just I pictured in my head
it's like it's more of a waking
nightmare
um
because I have to walk on the street at
a certain point where there's no
sidewalk and I have to round a corner
and there's a couple of treacherous
places and so I try to be really aware
of keeping the leashes short on the dogs
because they especially Jay doesn't like
to walk on the side of the road because
it's really uneven she wants to walk on
the even pavement which puts her in the
street and so I look behind me to see if
any cars are coming I can see a long way
and sometimes I would we can get up the
hill a lot easier if I let her do that
but I do have this thought of somebody
whipping around a corner or something
and hitting my dog
and I've just played it out of my head
that it'll be pretty quick I would
immediately scoop up my dog
get in the car with the person and
insist that and well first of all I
would be very angry and I would be what
are you thinking yeah I would be yelling
and saying
we needed you need to take my dog that
you've hit to the
to to the vet to the emergency vet right
now we're going
okay yeah does this seem like a good
plan because this is exactly what I'm
now I've visualized it so many times
I'm I just want to be ready for it you
know and I've taken off my shirt and
I've like wrapped it around the wound or
whatever if a leg is broken or you're
shirtless in the story I'm shirtless I'm
yelling I'm writing I've I've made
because people drive too fast how far
are you from home I think there's a rule
of thumb here
um a mile or less well but that's this
is precious time I feel like there needs
to be a minimum distance this is
precious time
if you're I think I kind of want to
punish the person by having them be the
one to take me all the way there
and get some blood in their car and
you know they're driving too fast how
bad is the dog off
uh broken leg there is bleeding I'm
stopped it with my shirt and I'm not
doing well at all
um
first of all and if Chrissy
why would I go home very traumatic day
for this person I know well what about
me and the and the dog not only does
this person have to deal with it this is
my worst nightmare that they hit a dog
right they have to deal with the fact
that the owner of said dog is getting
them to take it to the vet and the owner
of the dog happens to be you
like this is not a good day for that
person I definitely need him to give me
a rising with them to my house right
because I definitely have to get in the
car with them
right
um yeah I I honestly I think that most
people might volunteer that okay good
this has had to have happened
I think it's mostly like participated
Camp people will take you to your home
and then you would take the dog to the
emergency room
I think that's probably what happened
but then my kids are involved and
they're traumatized
um and if if Christie's not home this
person's taking me all the way let me
just okay because I need to be Googling
which one which one's the closest here's
the thing which I kind of know I think
the biggest
sort of the starting point
of the story of this scenario is where
you're getting off
off track okay I know you're gonna say
that I let Jade walk in the street no no
no no
and that's a good idea no I keep her
really close I'm not saying that she's
just right on the edge it is almost
impossible for the scenario that you're
envisioning to happen
people don't hit dogs that are being
walked yes it has happened
highly unlikely they get closer than I'm
I'm I'm I can't get further over dogs
who get hit by cars or dogs that are off
leash that are crossing the street
you know I've had uh
I had a dog I've had two dogs die as you
have told the stories in the book of
mythicality and one of them was jump
defense and crawl and crossed the road
and got hit
the other one was mysterious poisoned
yes
um but the uh but if I drop it I don't I
just think it's you're not gonna drop
the leash what are you well there's also
this the retractable leash and it goes
out really far and only Jasper's on you
said that you were keeping it close and
I do keep it close but what if nothing
but there's just one little button that
if the button gets hit then I'll and and
he sees a squirrel across the street
it I mean it could happen I I think
about this stuff
to decrease the chances of it happening
I don't think I just don't think it's a
legitimate worry
ing I know it sounds a little OCD at
this point but it does I don't think you
should worry about it I don't think this
is going to happen but if it doesn't
happen a couple weeks ago you got to be
300 yards or more I need to be thinking
about I need to be thinking about the
consequences of my actions more and here
I am doing that
well done
well done link right uh yeah well
I I don't think that this is a this is
actually this is misplaced concern
when you were driving Greg around nearly
falling on the edge of a mountain like
maybe slowing down around the blind
turns that would have been wise but this
is different all right so then I'll I'll
change subjects okay but this reminds me
I went go-karting oh me Lincoln and a
couple other friends like five of us
went go-karting and these are electric
go-karts indoor go-kart racing Warehouse
scenario we've done it like years ago
I think I've done it twice in my life I
did it more I did it pretty recently too
with my family that was in town and
there they had expanded the track
and it so it went through a whole new
area and the whole thing was different I
swear that the cars used to not be
electric but maybe maybe I'm thinking
about that place outside of Dunn
remember when that place outside of Dunn
the Fun Center opened up and they had
outdoor go-karts and they had uh like
those like
things on in the pool like bumper cars
in the pool
and I was like what I never I only went
like one time I only went once it's like
how on Earth does anybody
think in the middle of nowhere this is a
good idea oh it's done man I mean
people got it's a crack capital of the
world yeah it is
the thing about uh go-karting is that
first of all it is fun but it is
exhausting and at our age there's this
constant awareness that
something could go wrong in my body I
don't want to get hurt I know I don't
want to get hurt that's all I'm thinking
the whole time like I was like I'm gonna
buy two races but I'm not gonna buy a
third race because I feel like third
races when pushing your life what does
me in but you get on these things and
there was five of us and then in the
heat there's probably 10 or 12 people so
there's strangers that you're racing
against and this creates an interesting
Dynamic at top speeds of they'll go 45
miles an hour they feel crazy fast they
feel crazy fast and some of them are
harder to steer than others but they all
take a take a good amount of work to
like really hold in the turns this is
like an aggressive experience I really
liked it it's a little pricey but um the
the thing that I noticed was that
there's people who just aren't as
aggressive
and they ruin everything as I am and
that starts out fun because like you
finally come up behind these people and
you're like you're trying to get around
them and the turns are really tight and
there's a bunch of them so it's not like
you're just going 45 the whole time you
really gotta you gotta slow down you
gotta Bank you got you got to really
time your turns and be strategic about
it to get around these slow people and
they don't allow bumping yeah or side
swiping or any of that but it still
happens and when it happens
you're you're as close to this stranger
who you're side swiping as you and I are
right now yeah and so the look that's
exchanged
that's a I didn't anticipate how
precarious of a moment that is when it's
like I could reach out they could reach
out and grab my wrist pull me close and
safe
did you ever do that but they probably
won't but I definitely got some of those
looks
now I think differently about this just
so you know I I think differently about
go-karts than I do the UTV situation so
you're you're full bore
let them have it last time we went as a
group and you and I were there I got the
fastest time do you not recall this
of course not because it's not about the
fastest time it's about the most fun
yeah but you're talking about how
aggressive you're going I'm saying that
like I was slowing down so that people
could catch up so that I could be racing
with people like I go that's the fun as
balls to the wall as possible to win
because they do text you your it's a
result it's fun oh yeah they put it on
the board but it's it's so safe It Feels
So safe to me like if you go off the
track it's just you're just more
Warehouse
you know what I'm saying but what about
the part where you're like locking eyes
with a complete stranger that thinks
you're an uh that made me
uncomfortable well I haven't I've been
to the place that you're talking about
and every time I've been
everyone on the track at the same time
was somebody I went with that's when
it's fun that's the thing that happened
it was my family and an extended family
and stranger named some mythical folks
and then that time it was us and our
friend group so
and and we bump your friends and your
family like that's part of it oh yeah
until you get a warning and then you get
the second warning well I thought that I
was bumping a friend stranger I don't
know we liked eyes and that's what was
so
like jolting about it was oh this is a
complete stranger
like what's the conversation going to be
like when we all get out of our cars
take off our helmets and are walking
back to the snack bar
like that's when I like start I just
feel like it's kind of got a little
speed I just feel like it's it's get out
of it it's expected it's part of it
because I could tell by the way they
were driving they weren't and looking at
me they weren't expecting well the
bumping part is because you're trying to
find the Gap to pass them you're waiting
for them to go too wide into a turn and
then you then you go into inside them
yeah and then like you're gonna bump a
little bit and you might sideswipe
somebody but I think that's all fair
game I I feel differently about that
that doesn't feel like a safety issue
that feels like a social issue
oh yeah I think you have to try talking
about this really hard to hurt yourself
in one of those what you'd have to do is
you'd have to be
you have to hit somebody really hard
like somebody stationary and you hit
them yeah no no you can hurt them real
bad yeah more so than you'll hurt
yourself in the process but then I kind
of want to work there and flip those
things they have this I don't think so
they have this power to just like
remotely
turn off all of the carts there to do
this really slow them down yeah right
and so it's like a final lap if
something goes wrong
they bring everybody down and there's
nothing you can do about it and they you
gotta wait for them to bring you back up
but then the moment they bring you back
up and you don't know when it is you're
like slowly going behind somebody and
then all of a sudden
you're taking off that's like so I'd
like to be that I'd like to be on that
lever
so and I'm going to incorporate
you're like what I it's not I want to
come back and do this by myself or I
want to do this just completely
unhindered I want to be the guy who
controls all the cards
it slows everybody down speeds him up
holds up the signs no bumping no side
swiping well you were a ride operator
for a summer in Santa Cruz and you hated
every moment of it yeah it actually
sucked yeah so so maybe not Maybe not
maybe I'll be a driver but see I've got
I'm getting a lot of recreation under my
belt between that newfangled trampoline
the newfango carts I'm on The Cutting
Edge it's quite impressive of uh uh high
speed and jumping I don't think I would
do it I don't think I would do a
trampoline I can almost
promise you that that would be a bad
idea for me in my back the back
compression it's better this is better
on your joints yeah this is the one to
use yeah yeah I don't know I just don't
know if I'm gonna risk it I don't think
you can risk it but only five minutes at
a time
um
well you know what I've enjoyed catching
up I've enjoyed I've got more things but
I mean we can we can say that yeah sure
yeah we've been talking for an hour
that's enough for any anybody to talk
I got a
it's my wreck this week
um I made a new playlist I'll plug it
just to remind you sometimes I make
playlists uh it was the
it was last Saturday I was like you know
what I need a new like poolside pool
party playlist
so I made one pool party 2023. it's uh
it's available on timely on my Spotify
uh I think we might have three hours of
some nice
energetic what's the vibe
um what am I eating
you're swimming oh swimming you gotta
you got a cold beverage am I swimming am
I floating your ass is floating in a
tube and you got a cold beverage but
then you're also swimming and and maybe
doing some underwater Jiu Jitsu on my at
certain what's the tenor of the
conversation
[Music]
um
like hey man give me give me a give me a
hot dog okay all right got it throw me a
cold one pool party to 2023. yeah people
people are hanging out over somebody's
got the you know check out those cut off
shorts you shouldn't need a hot dog in
the pool though no not in the pool not
on a raft I'm getting out of the pool
you should not be reclined when eating a
hot dog
uh number one choking hazard the easiest
way I I can tell you to get to my
Spotify playlist is by going to my
Instagram profile and then it says my
Spotify playlist when you click on that
you can open Spotify and then you can
search for uh
pool party 2023
oh that's fair enough it was fun I tried
it that morning and then we had an
impromptu pool party that afternoon
because because Lily happened to be home
and it was hotter than the fouls out
there yeah and I was like hey let's do a
pool party I can try out my playlist
which gave me the confidence to make it
public
I think it works it's it's a it's a
previewed and fully experienced playlist
yeah there you go it's it's uh it's it's
pull tested
all right uh thanks for spending this
time with us remember that you can give
your feedback your insights and also
give us your questions by calling us at
1-888 earpod one was I supposed to say
the 188 part uh because I
uh you have you traditionally said it
but I mean just you know you can change
things up your dog can can walk on the
other side of the road you know yeah
or just use hashtag your biscuits
or basically the entire episode I
thought whenever you were talking about
inflexibility you meant whether or not
you could touch your toes that type of
flexibility I'm so confused the entire
time because I was like how is how is
this the toxic trait I don't get it and
then Brett chose it and gave the
definition and everything instantly
clicked anyway love you guys uh stay
Flexi
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]